peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais j'arrête
mes chers enfants vous avez que pour moi
aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas un dimanche comme
d'habitude puisse dans votre présence je
vais dire ma dernière messe à cet hôtel
je veux dire officiers de marins quand
je ne quitterai jamais votre charmante
petite bourgade
mais ma santé mon âge et monseigneur
l'évêque donc conseillé de céder ma
place à inclure est beaucoup plus jeune
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis 42 ans j'ai fais tout en mon
pouvoir pour vous aider à aimée et
vénérée notre seigneur jésus-christ
aussi aujourd'hui je vais vous demander
de faire une petite prière non pas pour
lui et pour moi et pour mon successeur
l'abbé daniel qui va arriver au début de
la semaine prochaine j'espère qu'il nous
apportera la paix et la prospérité
alors avec moi au nom du père mes chers
amis je vous informe qu'une quête va
être faite parmi vous pour perpétuer ici
le souvenir bien heureux de monsieur le
curé maxima savez bien que vu le vézina
je garde souvent la maison de monsieur
taillon pied la regarder ceux qui hier
par hasard as tu découvert dernière des
remises ce magnifique un autre est beau
il faudrait demander à monsieur
taillandier courrier l'antenne ce
tableau mais il rentre aujourd'hui à la
seconde où je le vois je le lui il est
signé du braque mais c'est un cadre du
19e siècle
mais ce tableau ou plus d'argent
vendredi non non non non non non non ça
m'étonnerait monsieur payant keno sec de
la brocante
le voilà choix bon je me suis dit et si
je ne veux pas passer quelque chose
alors jean voisine hui on m'a vu rendu
beaucoup de bretons pendant ces quatre
jours
oh pardon je vous présente ce dossier
alfredo un ami de paris j'ai vendu le
tableau
quel tableau du tableau qui se trouvait
derrière mézin celui-ci comment vous
avez trouvé le tableau prix et combien
vaut-il
c'est une copie du tableau vaut pas 3 ou
la vache m'en doutais ces tableaux
étaient vraiment classique mais dans un
musée à oued aïssi
on pourrait pas le faire à monsieur le
curé alors combien coûteront 10 panneaux
c'est impossible il est déjà vendu 2 0
un ami américain ridley je suis la
première déception
allez vous je suis sûr que notre
charmante voisine a déjà débattu le prix
du tableau nous le fait combien travail
est déjà tendue ouais je suis désolé
monsieur l'acheteur monsieur au nom de
la loi
je songe ordonne de novembre le tableau
c'est pour une bonne mois
anglais qu'il dédia l'amérique alors s
est allongée qui vient d'amérique
il a jugé que ça soit un anglais one
american vous me donner son adresse je
lui ai écrit sans fil voilà je ne le
connais pas ces parallèles et claudine
raynaud il faut réfléchir un petit peu
on va téléphoner à ce genre là et demain
ou dans la réponse au score d'accord je
compte sur vous sinon un crack
je vous fiche en prison pour
non-assistance un gendarme en danger
dachau je vous raconte pas mesdames
[Musique]
huile ne pas leur vendre je dois 100
millions ce tableau la galerie
évidemment pas douter les fauchés la
marque d'alençon véhicule a confié à mai
soit l'espace je m'en souvenir faut
trouver une solution rapidement
voilà je dormais j'étais bien tranquille
de parfum un sommet du tour a dit que
monsieur le maire un scandale sans
précédent dans ma commune je perdrais
mon képi meje 30 leur aide même à le
[ __ ] que monsieur le curé vous avez
bien fait de nous prévenir tout il faut
viser très vite il faut il faudra ses
premières décisions ne rien dire à
personne
il faut que j'attrape le coupable à la
surprise du rongeur enfin il faut que
j'aille à talmont successeur à garder
car l'abbé daniel non internet vous je
ma vie jamais atteint découvert
[Musique]
monsieur le curé maximale l'abbé daniel
à vous êtes au top
[Musique]
évidemment j'aurais dû plus pratique
pour voyager
c'est un point de vue moi voyez vous je
suis resté à la soutane en permanence
vous me direz c'est de mon âge qui
beaucoup d'écouté pour vous faire
plaisir je vous promet de garder la
soutane pendant au moins une semaine
entière ça sera mon cadeau de bienvenue
bienvenue à châtillon confidentiellement
je peux vous dire qu'on m'a volé le
produit d'une enquête
cette nuit vous rendez compte près d'un
million quoi breivik
alors évidemment chef de gendarmerie est
sur les dents mais quand même du tour
des comptes et racontez moi sans détails
j'adore comment vous adorez et oui les
autres exemples qui est c'est mon dada
et et les énigmes sans passion de votre
tête comme un des cerveaux passionné
mais d'où vous vient cette passion mais
je sais pas d'où ça dure et partout et
oui également que c'est ici et là
attention aux prix
[Musique]
et cette histoire de tableaux caché dans
l'art sert d'un brocanteur qui refuse de
le dans le chiffonne comme vous à mon
avis le voleur a voulu vous mettre dans
mes possibilités d'acheter de tableau
voilà le verdict ah oui seulement pour
prouver ça c'est autre chose
non je dois aller trouver ce brocanteur
je peux très bien vous y conduire
monsieur le curé vous erreur non je peux
y aller seul et divisé monsieur chiens
jetés chose de voir leur du petit pocket
non-dits brotcorne ce qu'ils ont le
niveau record des stocks en jeu sud de
san francisco
c'est drôle important pacte qui m'a
donné votre nom adresse et avec mon
associé enfin un ami qui habite chez moi
que vous devez avoir le contact vrai don
hay pour toi un américain
je travaille dans les tableaux mahler
américain thomas certes tu as raison mon
pote de cartes sur table c'est le
syndicat qui m'envoient syndic ça y est
ça y est le chantage à ça il fallait s'y
attendre avec les gens que tu fréquentes
à paris toi on vous a à l'oeil depuis un
mois vous êtes sur un joli coup - alors
comme on est en train de social entre
gens de la même corporation
ça sera une boîte de cash vu la torpille
donné le pognon d'un cas du curé le
pognon de quoi annoncer c'est une
affaire entre nous qui t'a fait renault
a refusé de merde t'as raison
j'ai pas de scrupules ans venu faillite
doucement de buts qui pourrait de plessé
évasive
il ya deux cent soixante mille francs
excuses ça me suffira ciao les mecs
mais payet dieu de vous pardonner
amen
[Musique]
une brique d'arcy le marché soit de
nouveau
[Musique]
mais non vous n'avez pas le droit à lyon
mais j'ai à faire avant que l'abbé
daniel célèbre sa première messe dans
notre église
je tiens à vous remercier tous pour
votre bon coeur qui a permis d'acheter
cette merveilleuse de statues de saint
maximin mont vénéré patron et homonyme
mes chers frères
que dieu fasse que mon successeur soit
un bon curry mais ce que je sais moi
c'est que c'est un bon détective
déclarer une disparition entre
alors qui a disparu on marche de piquant
bijoux il est coutumier du fait
je ne sais pas comment on ne sait pas
mais nous nous sommes mariés comme
depuis un mois que nous avons loué un
chalet sur la route de saint jean va
très bien je vais faire un rapport
malades voyez-vous une photo de la
personne
merci
[Musique]
c'est vrai que cet homme me ressemble un
peu enfin si j'étais blond et si je
portais une moustache
coïncidence de la vie pourquoi de
montrer vous cette photo parce que
monsieur le curé cette histoire la
disparition de monsieur corps blanc ça
me turlupine depuis cinq jours comment
voit la jeune mariée qui fichent le camp
et que personne ne retrouve toutes nos
recherches sont nulles mois sont-ils
riches
alexandre question de se curer dans 85%
des cas l'argent et le mobile du crime
et c'est bien ça qui va barbouille
écoutez moi elle très jolie femme mais
pas en dessous vendeuse dans un magasin
de cannes ils se rencontrent ils se
plaisent coup de foudre ils s'épousent
et ça fait un mois qu'il se promène à
travers la france ils ont dû arriver
chez nous ici il ya une dizaine de jours
ils ont loué une villa dans les arbres
bon lui par contre assez riche mais
attention je viens d'apprendre ce matin
au téléphone qu'il vient d'hériter d'une
vieille cousine milliards d'années à une
question monsieur le curé un oui sous
quel régime sont ils mal avec la
deuxième bon point pour vous monsieur le
curé réponse sous le régime de la
communauté
évidemment 20 ans manquait dans le genre
- m'ont appris à me méfier d héritage
fabuleux et des disparition subite mois
je vous ai des roses du curé voilà
[Musique]
bon ben voilà corbas madame importante
nouvelle
on a retrouvé votre mari mort quelle
horreur non nous pourquoi mort allait
bien vivant dieu merci
oui il est avec moi dans la voiture mais
ici ça a l'air de vous sembler
impossible madame alors pas du tout dans
ces émotions-là la joue comme je vous
comprends monsieur corbas sortait alors
on sortait un peu de courage
[Musique]
l'amour pardon combien toutes nos
petites querelles je suis si heureux
c'est pas mon mari comment enfin chérie
tu plaisantes non cet homme n'est pas
nicolas il lui ressemble à peu c'est
vrai que moi quand tu es enfant tu parce
que monsieur m'a montré ses papiers
d'identité faux papiers a pas pour moi
qui en ai versé ma dame ne t'inquiète
pas mon ange des minéraux un beau soleil
on oubliera tout petit 18
en attendant remercions le chef pour
nous avoir réunis alors voir chef
bravo pour ton mari je vous jure je suis
dans un piège épouvantable on va essayer
de me faire disparaître et pour quelles
raisons la région
quand l'argent c'est le nom marie votre
mari est très riche mais oui enfin une
vieille cousine la nuit est mort
quelqu'un êtes deux jours il va laisser
une petite fortune
si cet homme qui est là il va s'emparer
d'identité de nicolas ils sont peintres
a par ricochet de fortune et il nous
répétait l'idée c'est de me faire
disparaître ce que vous me racontez
rocambolesque nom pourrait coûter madame
admettons enfin alors votre mari le vrai
mais ça qu'ils se laisser dépouiller
comme ça sans rien dire justement c'est
pour ça qu'il faut leur trouver
d'urgence madame
il est introuvable si au moins on savait
où est le corps de votre mari un
accident ou quelque chose comme ça alors
j'aurai la preuve que cet homme là est
un imposteur
mais tant que je ne fais pas où est le
corps de monsieur corbeil ou encore
monsieur corbard madame oui bon je
réfléchis même très bien je viendrai
vous voir demain monsieur si vous ne
pouvez pas laisser en tête à tête avec
cet inconnu
écoutez moi bien jusqu'à preuve du
contraire cet homme est votre mari alors
donnez moi la preuve du contraire et je
vous en des livres mais jusque là allez
raout
[Musique]
et
ce n'est pas mon mari exact que
voulez-vous l'argent qu'est ce qu'on
croit
c'est pourtant simple je sais où est ton
mari si je le dis alors font payer pour
me perdre
[Musique]
j'en appelle la police tels des conseils
bons coups et bien monté et les papiers
tout en raid
j'ai eu nicolas
[Musique]
combien voulez vous
la moitié de l'héritage
[Musique]
on croit rêver
un cauchemar plutôt non je refuse tant
pis
je vais commettre un crime moi aussi
comme le tien
bah ouais m
ah oui
pour toucher la totalité de l'héritage
le supprimer
veuf j'encaisse tout
comme toi veuve tous voulaient tout
encaisser dac chef afin de bien d'avoir
une dépression nerveuse s'est suicidé
j'ai essayé d'intervenir je suis
désespéré voilà ce que je dirais
chapeau
non sans la professionnelle le vent a
tourné petite ordure tu ris pas tu veux
pas soyez chic à thème vous voit
maintenant ça le petit maître chanteur
je t'en foutrais mois 50 50
alors que j'ai dragué ce minable de
nicolas que je me le suis l'épousé est
supprimé
et tout ça tout seul j'ai décliné la
police recherche les coordonnées pologne
j'ai bien caché tu vas me fournir
l'occasion rêvée tu vas me faire le
corps de nicolas d'aoust type tu pars tu
l idée est elle passée
alors pour mon école à cet homme n'est
pas votre mari madame vous disiez
pourtant le contraire il ya un quart
d'heure et ça alors qu'est ce que c'est
cet homme est un dangereux gangster
l'avait échappé belle
c'est sans doute lui qui a assassiné
votre mari allait en mémoire le port de
salau dès que j'ai des nouvelles madame
bien entendu tout téléphone
bien entendu tablier voilà une grande
nouvelle encore on a retrouvé cette fois
votre mari il est dans un hôpital est
dans le coma mais je vais éclaircir ce
mystère
[Musique]
savoir possible je deviens folle moi il
ya vol
[Musique]
à
les
[Musique]
merci du renseignement madame
et mes félicitations à monsieur le curé
qui a très bien joué le mort avec une
balle à blanc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le temps qu'ils attachent sa chaussure
je fais quelques pages mortes ou gilbert
desport j'en veux bien si l accès
paraître de plaisanter léopold le hon
pour nous quelle honte pour mon église
mes frères je suis mieux de
consternation
mais c'est le curé oui les churchill
balle je voudrais bien d'un film de will
est ce que quelqu'un c'est will see
s'est envolé avec samir avec sonia sa
bonne amie une belle rousse sicogi n'est
pas encore mariée et donc tu n'es pas
encore peiné ce pas monsieur le curé
écoutez franchement c'est une subtilité
de langage qui n'a rien à voir avec la
liturgie mais il fonctionne à rien
soixante couverts et j'ai payé d'avancé
mais non ça porte malheur moyer la
preuve
non mais vous vous croyez ou là pardon
mon dieu excusez moi c'est le moment
j'ai tellement envie de me donner une
idée voilà je vais partir à la recherche
du fugitif
ça danse ça risque de me prendre une
heure ou deux alors en attendant
patienter je vous promets que cet
après-midi tout sera rentré dans l'ordre
et que nous pourrons célébrer le mariage
monsieur le curé on vous fait confiance
allez-y mais qu'est ce que nous ferons
dans ce temps là est bien le grito il
paye et on va manger
il ya du cochon grillé chez que vous
aimez ça c'est moi qui ai donné l'idée
[Musique]
oui mademoiselle sonia est parti depuis
ce matin elle marigot sa note elle a
fait son plein d'essence et vous n'avez
pas une petite idée de l'endroit où elle
a pu aller chercher je sais qu'elle a
fait dans le pays un stage comme
démonstratrice en parfumerie mais pas
refuser oui la démonstratrice sonia
c'est ça à bas la finition de travail
avant-hier puis depuis je n'ai jamais
revu et vous savez pas où elle a
l'habitude d'aller danser s'amuser
une fois quand il était jeune beau riche
et un certain albert un rigolo
bebert bon merci
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur les verres bonjour les
purs et dites moi il ya les voyous qui
ont crevé le pneu avant de la petite
voiture sport qui est garée dans la
voiture-bar dollars
c'est ça à l'époque la moitié ont bon
dos on vient de crever 1-2 avant les
vaches mangent pas chéri joel je vais a
dû changer la roue venais de finir dès
ce samedi
[Musique]
j'ai mes amis rappelle comme si le curé
c'est un grand talent j'ai une amie à
moi qui la bat qui déjeune avec son
frère qui adore les bébés vous étiez
gentil de me prétends oui je vais le
montrer
permettez tout faisant durer
voilà bien un petit françois est avec
moi voilà
monsieur le curé quelle surprise de
combat je suis très heureux de vous
trouvez vous savez où gilbert
oui mais tentera de réparer la route ma
voiture je pense monsieur le curé que
vous êtes venu nous faire la morale
on est fatigués pas me servir à rien non
j'ai pas faire un mariage annulé un
mariage malheureux ça c'est gentil ça
moi vous vous êtres et le coeur
intelligent vous êtes un curé de shark
c'est ça le choc
il ya un petit problème parce que je
voudrais savoir oui gilbert parce qu'il
faut que je lui donne son petit panneau
quand sa mère il a fait ce petit à une
infirmière de l'hôpital je parle pas de
celui qui la ferme modèle rose de la
poste non plus au sud à jos et dans sa
mère a su qu'il épouse et mireille elle
devait de me trouver et elle va donner
le prix je donne en irak et l accord sa
marque comme vous partez vous avec
gilbert j'ai pensé que fait c'est normal
je pourrais vous le confirme
[Musique]
la voilà les minions soyez heureux les
chers enfants soyez heureux rien ne vaut
les absences elle recevait la
bénédiction d'un curé qui a horreur du
lanceur mais je suis pressé je vais
mettre les mignons
[Musique]
alors gilbert prépare au monsieur le
curé pardon pardon vous devez mot dire
non non je te souhaite seulement du
courage non pas que sonia ne sont pas
gentils mais il va falloir travailler
dur pour vous 3 ou 3 ah oui vous deux je
suis bébé
le bb bag est levée elle est venue
rompre en eci du temps pension elle tint
pas dit ça vient voir la fenêtre tous
marrant
là le scandale est irréparable
je pense
[Musique]
il
le déshonneur mireille s'est envolé avec
léopold le garçon de neuf ans
certains potes maintenant c'est la fille
qui s'est envolé alors je vous en
supplie faites pas retrouvé la fugitive
pour l'honneur de mon église
par pitié
[Musique]
buts
vers tous les quatre dans la boue
saint-antoine de padoue
merci pour ce beau coup double
[Musique]
la libye n'est pour rien jeunesse avec
les analystes toujours à leur père il
faut comme en valeur de symbole toujours
amoureuse du même évidemment malheur
c'est qu'elle pourrait que sa mère
[Musique]
tiens madame et quand j'ai enlevé au nom
et onglets vous pouvez l'emmener keller
pauvre madame et tout sens dessus
dessous
le vol semble être le mobile du meurtre
non non non toute aide et fouillé mais
rien de précis n'a disparu parce que
madame de salleboeuf recevait des gens
douteux grâce à son argent elle vivait
tranquillement ne savait presque
personne sauf à lui qui sera lui bien le
jeune homme a rue je sais je sais tout
dans les petites bourgades du tout s'est
vite
sylvain un bon à rien beau donc
paresseux mais bon je croyais qu'il
travaillait dans son exploitation
agricole non il fait semblant
il vit avec sa soeur dans une ferme que
le reste et leurs parents mais c'est
elle qui était marché la sphère pauvre
marié oui pour mourir
silva
[Musique]
m
hu a été tuée cette nuit
quelle horreur mais comment ça je sais
pas j'ai pas eu de détails j'ai appris
ça par un routier qui prenaient de
l'essence en même temps que moi c'est ça
m'a foutu un choc parce que elle et moi
on était très amis rôle à l'âge c'est
tout le monde le sait alors surtout ne
mendie pas plus simple donc jugé pas mal
je ne juge personne moi alors qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour toi j'ai peur
qu'on fasse des histoires toute cette
boue convard mais ça va être terrible
surtout vis-à-vis de ma soeur vis-à-vis
de ta soeur et pourquoi pas si on me
reproche sans arrêt la vie que je mène
alors il va triompher à la vérité le me
déteste elle me jalouse je mène depuis
des années la vie qu'elle a toujours
rêvé de mener si elle avait été moi je
veux dire plus je lis tu as her s'occupe
du domaine d'été par an il ya les
vertueuses oui bon dis moi oui
j'espère que tu as la libye oui pourquoi
je passais la soirée à la ferme avec ma
cervelle
[Musique]
car c'est un diamant n'est ce pas
mademoiselle maria
que se passe t'il un crime a eu lieu
dans notre commune
la nuit dernière à 23 heures exactement
alors sans vous dire ni pourquoi ni qui
je viens vous demander un témoignage
officiel le kent où étiez vous hier à 23
heures précise ici etiez-vous seul avant
de vous répondre puis savoir qui a été
tué madame de salleboeuf qui voyage je
suis obligé de dire la vérité
j'ai passé la soirée seul mon frère
n'est rentré que très tard à l'eau mais
tu es complètement folle tu pourras tu
mens à sa salle tu as tué cette vieille
femme et tu veux que je couvre ton crime
et bien n'y compte pas il ya trop
longtemps que je suis à vous de courage
avec toi petite crapule
non je ne vois pas un faux témoignage
j'étais servi de domestique de
souffre-douleur dhr et bien c'est fini
tu attends c'est fini merci de votre
témoignage
l'arrière nous rentrons l'agent d'ambri
embarqués dans la n 1 mondiale
[Musique]
vous
qu'est ce que je vous dise vous
prétendez avoir un alibi vous n'avez pas
pourquoi après l'étrange partir sur lui
à nos amours
c'est complexe et sordide il semble
vouloir se venger
malheureusement le tribunal sera
impressionné une soeur qui vous adore et
qui témoigne quand d'entre vous c'est
grave
alors tout est clair avouez sylvain que
c'est vous qui avait étranglé votre
maîtresse mais avouez dont non mon frère
est un danger public
si le chef le livre il recommencera a
tué une de vous une bouffée roulements
s'il faut obliger la police à l'arrêter
ça oui c'est pour ça qu'il faut
manifester à l'est
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe elle est devenue
complètement folle est en train
d'ajouter tout le village
j'avais pensé puisque l'espèce ont
vocation à l'attroupement dégradation
monuments publics
vous méritez un mois de prison
excellente idée en prison je serai en
fait en sûreté car si vous relâchez
silva vous exagérez
bravo parfait et moi je dire au tribunal
que vous vous êtes acharné contre le
témoin et que vous avez tout fait pour
protéger le coupable coupable c'est
d'avoir deux frères n'avaient pas été
levées madame de saint molf il coulait à
ses côtés une vie dorée
deflem d'insouciance de les curés
défendant le visent de mieux en mieux
tandis que vous moi mais oui vous vous
détestiez madame de sainte beuve qui
vous avait pris entre guillemets votre
frère n'est ce pas eh bien oui je la
détestais et puis après donc il se
pourrait que ce soit vous ayez tué
madame hince à neuf mois à 23 heures
j'étais tranquillement à la ferme
j'espère que vous avez des témoins eh
bien oui puisque nous étions enfin que
continuer non
vous alliez dire puisque nous étions en
train de jouer aux cartes
mon frère et moi vous êtes tombés dans
le piège
merci de votre témoignage silvan vous
êtes libre monsieur le curé bras long
quelle idée géniale pas eu de charges et
le chien le chat la n va et vient
consolider la folie
enfin d'ici si j'avais témoigner à la
première seconde
oui mon frère est avec moi à 23 heures
etc etc on aurait douté on aura compris
que je te défouler tandis qu'en de
charges en rétractant c'est différent
j'ai foi quand même tu aurais pas dû lui
tordre le cou à ces vieilles tours je
vais simplement dit lui barboter
quelques objets de valeur de temps en
temps mais elle m'a vu on s'est battu
mais bon c'est pas grave dans un mois
voilà faire et on chante vère
[Musique]
parce que voulait faire aussi une façon
peu gentil de vous accueillir les
entremetteuses disparaît c'est non non
j'ai quelque chose à vous dire et qui va
beaucoup et le bec
ah oui oui cette pauvre madame st bo
avant de mourir a dû avoir un dernier
sursaut elle a eu la force d'écrire le
nom de son assassin sur un petit bout de
papier qu'elle a froissé et jetée sous
un meuble
c'est pour ça je ne les retrouve et que
ce matin en revanche à la maison alors
je suis venue tout de suite vous pourrez
venir sans avertir personne
vous allez me donnez tous votre argent
liquide
aussi nous et ouais j'ai mis ce petit
papier nous cette pauvre dame dit que
vous l'avez vous les régulièrement il ya
[ __ ] oui à gravelines est alors à
pied ou non non non je vous jure j'ai
jamais eue papier papier
[Musique]
elle a raison il n'y a jamais eu papier
j'ai l'impression que tout discours
supplémentaires et super füle
n'est ce pas monsieur le curé à part
qu'il faut féliciter mademoiselle alice
pour son excellent numéro de comédie et
pour son courage oh mais je n'ai pas eu
vraiment peur les structures et je
savais que vous étiez gagnant le nu sont
taboues frères et soeurs criminelles
associées prier pour que dieu soit plus
indulgents que la justice et
souvenez-vous qu'en campagne souvent le
chien est l'ami du chat c'est cet oubli
qui vous a perdu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]